hey welcome back to the edge with your
boy Michael Parsons live on the bleach
Report app let's get right into it we
had a big one we played Sunday Night
Football we just had a big game against
the charger Chargers Monday night
football game last night and it came
down to a wire and it was a wild one so
let's build this up and we just gonna
start off rip a lot of y'all was talking
about me and how I walked into the
stadium with my bags and y'all also
heard the headphones I was like I got a
$100 for anybody that could say that
anybody knows who who I was listening to
and what song I was listening to like
what would get me into that Groove like
what would you think is my intro song
like and I'mma just let y'all know what
the song was a little bit later but let
me know in the chat who y'all think give
me your best guesses the chat's live
today so I want to hear what you guys
say and don't forget to drop your
questions into the chat I want to hear
what you guys think what you guys want
to know and things like that but what's
all in the bags as I would say is I got
to have my kelvie that's basically like
a contr it gets me hot cold and and the
other bag had the attachment so I could
put it one on my knee one on my ankle
basically just getting me game ready you
know G ready for the game uh before I
get to the stadium while I'm at the
stadium and things like that I might
just use heat uh as soon as I get to the
stadium but bring in all my Necessities
that I need so that way I can succeed on
game day and obviously I gotta have you
know just my my clothes and stuff as
y'all see I don't really dress up too
much I'm all about just listen I'm
throwing my sweats on I'm throw my
jacket on and we just F to go outside
and just have a braw that's how I always
look at it man I ain't looking to
impress nobody pregame I ain't looking
to get nobody excited I want to know you
know sh let's get straight into it like
I want to get into business hey hey
whoever that was that said firsters
shooter uh hey you exactly right because
when he dropped who to go who to go who
to go that's exactly where I was bumping
that new Drake album Andy we got get in
touch I owe you $100 because that's
exactly what it was bro um it was
obviously exciting game let's look at my
sack and the F final draft let's take us
back to this play um what was going
through my mind so literally we was
running fourman games obviously they was
sliding chipping things like that and I
was like man if we get a opportunity we
should go to a fiveman uh
pressure uh and you can see jron Cur
coming off the edge I knew I would end
up getting a one-on-one with a guy that
I knew I could beat I just hit it
relentlessly they still try to come uh
you know double team me but I just was
able to break through and get the
crucial sack that we needed uh to end
the help in the game because then of
course my guy Gilly lock the man the guy
that came to help this wi the Super Bowl
came over and ended the game and that's
what he do man Gilly loocks a legend
Hall of Famer and you know he told me
when he was at the coach he was thinking
about coming over here I got excited um
but man I'm so glad he came over here
the wisdom uh the type of guy he is bro
could be more happy uh to play with a
guy like that uh I say I do gotta play
with an extra gear and uh in the time
like that especially you know coming off
a big L um coming off you know a time
where a lot of people may have doubt uh
you know a lot of people were saying
some things I was like let let me just
let me just hang back a little bit let
me just show these people what I got and
you know we practiced them situations so
much time offense defense um going
against tiring in them positions Martin
uh in them positions Tyler Smith uh just
giving me those great looks that when I
go out to and see other guys it's just
it's just nothing but it's not it's just
it's just no it's like no one that can
compare to them those are guys I think
Tyler Smith's gonna be a pro bowl guy
and obviously Ty and Zach what they've
done so man those situations we practice
all the time so you know coach came to
me on the sideline was like Hey you
gotta go in this game and you know that
was my mentality soon as I stepped on
the field all tired or not we just had
to let everything loose so so that was
really exciting um my thoughts on the
Chargers this season I think they're a
great team uh they're not far off uh it
sucks losing Mike Williams the way they
did I think you add Mike Williams with
Keenan Allen and it just changes their
whole thing like losing Mike Williams is
so crucial um and you know I kind of
talked about a pre-draft trying to get
Quin Johnson to replace Mike Williams is
hard you know especially coming in the
league you got to grow you got to learn
the system you got to learn uh the smart
routes things like that to make it
easier for your quarterback um but it's
also hard uh so you know losing Mike
Williams is definitely uh tough but I
think they still have a great defense uh
the way that I seen them contain our
offense a little bit um but we also made
some explosive plays and we'll get in
more into that later but the Chargers
they're very close away they losing
these games they lost to the Dolphins by
a small margin they lost to us by a
small margin uh they're this close to
being a very good team so uh I think
they're on their way they're sprouting
up they're doing what they're supposed
to do besides that the energy was great
in La every time I've been to La it's
been an amazing atmosphere I played the
Chargers my rookie year amazing uh I
played the Rams my second year been
amazing and playing the Chargers again
and Sofi is amazing they obviously have
a top three stadium in the NFL I mean
Cowboys Nation I felt like that was a
home game like y'all took over the
stadium that game was so electric like
we all felt the energy the whole way I
mean we see Jay-Z and Lebron at the game
like last night um it's kind of weird
because LeBron also mentioned that he
wasn't a Cowboys fan anymore so we could
take a look at
that you know after LeBron's admitting
that he's not a Cowboys fan it's kind of
weird to see him here but you know
LeBron said he used to be a Cowboys fan
now he's a Cleveland Fan listen Braun
this is what I'm gonna say to you
bro I I feel you on that but listen we
he you know your boy here I see you talk
highly of me listen the dogs is here bro
come on Braun stay true to who you want
to be with you want to be with Cowboys
Nation come back bro like keep believing
like same I I remember talking to Jay-Z
at the white party he's like man just
seem like y'all just not hungry no more
well Jay and brown we hungry we coming
we we still trying to grow keep
believing hey don't give up on this yet
but listen we gonna get into Cleveland
in the second we're going to get into
Cleveland in the second just be prepared
for that I don't want to ruin it too
early but we're getting back into the
Cleveland and second um but you know
also we got to talk about Troy Aman's
comment about him saying Jay-Z is his
doppelganger I just want to say hold on
Troy hold on I don't know where you got
this from um but this is so far off this
is so far off um I do not see this at
all I don't know where you could be
finding this um this was actually just
insane of a comment like just completely
far off I do not see the resemblance at
all come on Troy um just just no we got
to end that right now um but I hadn't
had a chance to see everything from last
night but I heard there was a crazy
Chargers fan um that's been going viral
I've been seeing her everywhere uh this
was actually insane she had to be some
type of fake person like I don't know
who this came from like where she came
from um but this was a very depressing
woman like there's just no way like the
highs and lows in football are really
crazy and one of a kind so this was
actually kind of funny to see um but
let's get straight into the business now
like Chargers week done we're going into
the bu week and we'll get more to that
uh later but I want to say welcome back
to my guy Cooper cup welcome back we
miss you brother I always said as soon
as you came back with Nico it would be
special and you really showed that seven
receptions pretty much a buck 50 and a
touchdown Cooper cup welcome back we
missed you in the NFL we missed your
presence and you show why man hey I bet
your fantasy people are happy that you
are back I know that for a fact uh I
know that for a fact that your fantasy
people are happy to be back I'm happy to
see you back I can't wait to see you
next week in AT&T Stadium I can't wait
uh bro you're an exceptional player uh
you you you do things the right way and
it's just always amazing to see um you
know I want to talk about the 49ers and
the Eagles both lost last week so now
there are no more undefeated teams left
and let's just talk about those losses
and death because I want to say why
they're not important um but they're
very important especially because what
we talked about on this thing and how
y'all portrayed the Dallas Cowboys and
how the media portrays the Dallas
Cowboys because I got time today so
let's get into it and I heard Joy Taylor
I heard all the other people they said
we didn't have a significant win they
said we beat a half a a a a nameless
Zack Wilson or you know a team without
Aaron roders and all these things but
guess what one thing that we did have
that the jet did have was s Garner DJ
Reed um and they were also missing a few
other pce and they were missing Aaron
Rogers but um but they beat the Eagles
but apparently the the Jets aren't a
significant win they aren't a good team
without Aaron Rogers which I said wasn't
true and I'm glad that that Zack Wilson
is proving people wrong he beat a great
Eagles team now the Jets are three and
three they're putting themselves in a
position and say hey Aaron's throwing
now and we have the pullup of Aaron
throwing the ball now let's bring that
up Aaron's throwing the ball now if he
if his ailles can heal I think that
Aaron has a chance to come back in late
January and have a chance to make a
playoff run if they can find a way to
go nine and seven and become a seven six
seed or they come or 10 and seven 10
like whatever it is they have a chance
for Aaron Rogers to come back and make a
run for the Super Bowl and a high
playoff chance without a doubt but I
just don't condone the bashing of Dak
Prescott and the Dallas Cowboys and have
the same energy for the
Eagles the Eagles were healthy they had
Jaylen Herz they had the receiver core
they had their explosive weapon they
didn't have Lane Johnson I will admit
that they didn't have Lane Johnson but
does that make that big of a difference
because I see my
quarterback you know maybe not have the
red zone success but mve Deva way better
than the Eagles
did uh Sunday night so we want the same
energy for everybody because there's a
whole bunch of bashing when it's Dak
Prescott but not the same when it's the
Eagles I got time today okay a lot of
people said the Browns defense was
overhyped everyone said Michel don't no
ball I said the Browns are the real deal
if they could put it together they could
be a hard team to beat and now I can say
it we miss my guy who we miss very much
Amar Cooper Bal the hell out like he
could have been the dog of the week what
he did to help lead his team over the
49ers was amazing that catch was
spectacular
um the Browns and and I heard a quote AO
said this which which pissed me off he
said I'm not worried about the 49ers
they were missing Christian mcaffrey
they were missing Debo Samuel this what
piss me off about that okay they started
that game the Browns were missing
Deshawn Watson they were missing Nick
chub they were missing Jack cin they
were missing them key
factors before the game even started so
why is it that we are just scrubs and
we're nobodies that don't deserve to be
on the field and we're just all talk but
there's aund excuses for these other
these other teams like if y'all just
gonna hate Cowboys Nation just say y'all
hate Cowboys Nation but don't sit here
and throw shade on us keep the same
energy for everybody that's all it is
the bronze is a good team they are going
to continue to progressing and be the
great team I don't I don't know if we
have the stat line but bring it up I
think they gave up over a th a th
thousand their third best in the uh six
gamees span it's like a thousand
something yards I saw that statistic
like that's amazing defense this Browns
defense is the real I said they could
put it together they have all the pieces
they have miles Garrett um I mean Denzel
Ward I mean they still have gr delpit
Maron like I'mma just keep going about
this Browns defense that I see that a
lot of people are stepping on if their
offense could get it together they're
going to be a playoff team which I said
week one everything I stated I told you
I'm never gonna get on this podcast and
say unlike these other analy who don't
want to do their job and just say our
players trash or they're bad at football
which isn't true if you're in the NFL
you're a good football play I'm never
gonna get on this and say you're bad at
football okay let's just put like these
Ed are too lazy to do their job and
actually look at football and look at
lineups but I will and we're going to go
through the breakdowns and do the real
talking everything that c since week one
have have not failed and has been true
and we're just I just calling out the I
just want the same energy for everybody
because people I feel like those
analysts are failing
you okay now it's oh so now we should
look at the Jets now okay the Jets have
a chance to be a really good team okay
they just beat The Undefeated eagles
which people said was impossible to do
um and the the significant part is that
I think that's great about the Jets is
they lost sauce they lost their DJ Reed
um they're without Aaron Rogers but
they're saying if we could beat the best
team I don't know what more of a
confidence booster what was it three
picks and they had a force fumble in
that game they're saying if we could
beat the best team in the NFL which
people say right um and we're doing this
without our star players how special can
we really be and that's a significant
part about adversity and the next ManUp
mentality and that's the part that a lot
of people don't want to talk about
football in life think about in life all
right if you get punched in the face
right okay you get punched in the
face how do you react after you get
punched in the face like like if you
lose your job do you say oh my gosh I
lost my job like I can't move on or do
you say oh I got to go start applying I
got to get back on my feet I gotta find
a new job I got to like that's important
into how great they want to be the
leadership that's in the Jets locker
room is amazing and I'm loving to see it
like I said I I hope the best for the
Jets because everyone trashed on them
everyone trashed on Zack and I'm loving
the turnaround I'm loving it because
before before when we beat them it was
like they're nobodies who cares you know
um especially after they beat the bills
on uh what was that Sunday night or
Monday night the first week so I'm
loving to see it I'm sorry you guys do
not pay attention to these trash
analysts who just come out there and
rant after one game and I'm not even
saying the 49ers shouldn't have won the
game they had a chance to win the game
but I'm saying the Browns defense is a
real deal this is a special team that
they are building they still didn't have
deshan watching they're still missing
their two All Pro players so it's it's
special to see and I'm just calling out
the BS because I'm tired of people
trashing my quarterback I'm tired of
people trashing my team and that's why I
had nothing to say to the meia this week
I just wanted us to say you want to hear
me talk come hear me talk on the edge
Monday night um and and that's just what
is going be because I have nothing to
say because if you're just going to take
one game and say this is who I am then I
have nothing to say to you because in
life that's just not how it is um it and
that's Point Blank period not one moment
in your life will ever Define you you
have the next day you have a beautiful
opportunity that day will end and if
you're blessed enough you have if you're
blessed enough to wake up the next day
then you have you you have a chance to
redeem yourself you have a chance to get
better you have a chance to learn so
just take that lesson from the just take
that lesson chat and that's all I'm G
say about that I'm glad we can move on
from that um because you know I'm I'm
just tired of the disrespect and that's
just point blank period um and I'm tired
and I want y'all to get the full
breakdown of what sports really is uh my
next thing is the Bills beat the Giants
on Sunday uh the Giants were up 60 at
half time but everyone's talking about
the poor clock management at the end of
half um I just felt like the Giant and
and and this was um I don't I think in
this position uh with no timeouts you
definitely take a shot um but maybe they
trusted it um they might not had one of
the lead the hands in Tyrod Taylor but I
think Tyrod Taylor played a great game
and that would bring speculation like do
you leave on the back of Tyrod Taylor if
Daniel Jones can return like I think
Tyrod Taylor can continue to win games
for this Giants team I think if y'all
give him opportunity um that Tyro Taylor
can do his thing I I don't think he is a
bad quarterback I think he's a great
backup and I think he's not far off from
Daniel Jones so and the way he played
looked way more sound and better putting
together drives you know taking what
given getting away the ball um he didn't
give as many sacks up and I think that's
something to notice he didn't give up
that many sacks and they were still
without Andrew Thomas and more so we
need to we that's something the Giants
should look at you can win games with
Tyrod Taylor and their defense stepped
up big time uh my reaction to play call
like I said I you know every offensive
coordinator is different you know you
got guys that are aggressive that's like
man we got guys that's gonna take a shot
but I definitely think you take a charge
of the end zone um it's just not
something that you just want to give up
they that's three points that could have
been crucial in that game and you saw
had that game finished and I yes I did
think that that game was a pi that game
was a pi you know at the end of the game
I thought Darren Waller should have got
a pi but whatever but I want to get into
a guy who I've been going back and forth
with on this stream um and yes it's been
pretty hectic with this guy and yes um
we always go back and forth and my guy
to cheetah I mean he really could have
been my dog of the week but he's been
doing it so consistently it's almost
like we would have to make him dog of
the week every week Tyreek had another
big game six receptions 163 yards and a
touchdown and he he decided to get a
little jiggy with it and um he phone
recorded a backflip like really bro like
is this what you on this year I don't
know if y'all saw that stat he's on Pace
to have over 2,300 yards he has aund and
something yards short of a thousand
yards in six games do y'all know how
special that like that he is just so
rare in the NFL like we're never going
to see a cheetah and I don't even think
y'all saw he's already career marked
9,000 yards this man is a legend he has
a chance to hit 10K in one season I
think he's he's without a doubt he's
going to do it he's going to get over
600 yards so he's gonna hit 10,000 this
season I'm putting it on him um to get
that but let's hear what Shannon sharp
said about this so we could bring up
this next
discussion Tyre kill the most valuable
non-quarterback in the NFL yes he's
completely changed the way the Miami
Dolphins does business before he arrived
there the Dolphins was 27th in total
offense 22nd and 25th the 49ers finished
sth and 21 5ifth and 22 they're seventh
this year he's one of the few guys in
the history of the game that can take a
5 yard Route and turn it into a 80- yard
spectacular he's a threat legitimately
to hit his head on the goal post every
time he touched the football he is the
most dangerous man regardless of
position that man number 10 5'8 195 lbs
strikes more fear in the heart of
opposing coaches than any current player
because of that speed and his ability to
break the game open at any moment give
me
Tyre I I mean I can't agree more I think
offensively and even
defensively he's a top three without a
doubt unarguably one of the best most
valuable players in the NFL his ability
to take a screen for 50 a screen for a
house call uh the way they're motion him
out SL sending him across the field uh
his streaks out and UPS his double moves
his ability to get open is something
that we haven't seen in so long and the
credit that we have to say is he's doing
it without the greatest quarterback of
our era and that's Patrick Mahomes and
we're just talking about right now we're
not talking about Tom Brady Tom Brady's
obviously the goat but the the greatest
quarterback right now who's been
dominating these past four or five years
Tyre Hill started with him he said he
bet on himself said I don't need Pat
I'mma go over here with Tua he said Tua
is accurate Tua can take me to where I
want to be and he was not wrong and he
is still doing his thing yes Pat is
still successful and you're saying now
you're saying these both these both
these guys are successful without each
other they're both great players and
that's why they're the best at each
other their position Tyreek Hill is the
best wide receiver in the NFL right now
Patrick Mahomes is the best quarterback
in the NFL right now you see why they
had success but now you're seeing them
adjust and have the same success with
each other they're
you know I mean Tyreek Hill he's a
special bro like there's nobody like him
like it's one thing because we see guys
with speed we see guys with 4-2 speed
right but they're not getting open like
he does we see guys with 4-2 speed that
don't cut like he does we see guys with
that four two speed that can't that
doesn't catch like he does Tyreek Hill
special and without a doubt he's the
most valuable player in the NFL if y'all
don't put him at one he's definitely top
three um without a doubt I mean there it
shouldn't even be an argument I think
people are putting two on Pace for MVP
we should talk about Tyreek Hill for on
Pace for MVP if he goes for 2,300 yards
big Calvin Johnson's record he should be
the MVP of the NFL I mean without a
doubt I mean yes Tu has to throwing the
ball but he's the one getting open right
he's the one that's catching the ball
he's the one that's being amazing he's
the one like they're finding ways to
scheme I mean and that's why you give
credit to offensive coordinate they're
finding ways to scheme him to get him in
them positions but I mean he's doing
he's doing everything he can uh to do it
so man can't wait for Christmas day to
go against this cat I mean I played him
once super exciting match up but to see
it again I mean and see what he's doing
now man man oh man it's beautiful to see
and a team that's been quietly running
through the league is the Lions they've
won four straight games let's listen to
how fired up Dan Campbell was after this
I got a couple of things for you look
what I got in my back pocket anybody see
what that is I think got a
five five I got something else here
it'sing
five five
gentlemen hey and this is I think Dan
Kim was a great coach uh you talking
about a guy who came in there and had
extraordinary belief and Faith to get
turning that organization around and
doing last year they were one game away
from being a playoff team now this year
they're probably leading they're they
are leading the NFC on their division
this is a special team this is a team
that's going to be a playoff team that
we're gonna have to face later on the
season that we have to be ready for they
have everything I mean it's really
special what he's been able to do this
year the talent they in place over there
I mean it I mean I mean and it's great
and you look at Jared G another big
outing against the Bucks they lose to
5-1
if jerck G for top 10 QB in the
NFL production wise and what he's been
able to do you can argue it but if you
if you really break down we have to
break down every top 10 quarterback so
we can't just place Top like it's hard
like I have to break down who who is our
top five QBs I think we all know and
then you really have you can argue for
every top 10 it it's very close but the
way he's been able to conquer and beat
the odds and say hey the Rams got the
Rams got rid of me but I have still I
have more fight in me he reminds me a
lot of Kurt right two guys that people
don't necessarily believe in but are
still proving people wrong and that's
what you love to see in the NFL guys
that are not saying hey I may not be
with you so-called Premier tier one guy
but I still got Dogg of me I still got
fight of me and jarro G's been balling
ever even last year he was balling so
this is really great to see I mean keep
proving people wrong uh JG I love to see
it hey I continue to keep progressing
and be to that top 10 top quarterback
Lane that people don't want to do put
you there but I mean the way you've been
hooping I mean I don't see why they
wouldn't Jamar Chase had a 7-Eleven
chain on this week I mean I don't see a
guy that's not marking himself better um
because like he said he's always open
and a guy who's a 7-Eleven guy himself
it he said it is my guy CD seven
receptions 117 yards
yesterday I mean CD's always been
special I'm glad he's getting his
opportunities and I heard a guy say that
he's not a tier one receiver how
disrespectful can you be see one thing I
hate about former players is right I
don't even think that I think they just
say these things as if like they're
still playing right like they just say
already things like as if they still
playing and they as if they don't know
how it is to be out game plan or not be
in the best position to suceed sometimes
and they be forgetting about these
aspects these twixs and kles in the game
that you can't always control like CD's
in a he can't control how many times the
ball come his way he can't control what
the offense calls he just has to do his
best job at his ability but I see this
man work I see this man grind what he
puts in practice what he puts in the
game and when he does get his op his
opportunities he always takes advantage
of him tier CD is a tier one forer for
sure my top five always open receivers
in the game are I think number one we
gotta go Tyreek Hill um number
two uh this is hard uh we gotta go
Devonte Adams um I think those are the
top two I think you look at Jamar
Chase I mean obviously
uh Justin Jefferson and sedan lamb you
know what I'm saying I think that's my
top five always open receivers in the
game like without a doubt those is
probably the top five receivers in the
league
um and y'all want to know why okay why
I'm wearing you know my PSU hoodie I
don't know if y'all know but this is the
biggest week this is the biggest week
ain't a bigger
rivalry ain't a ain't going to bring
more commotion the Jersey is the back
that pen State jersey is the back now
okay there's nothing bigger than Penn
State Ohio State it's time it's time to
go to
war pen like there there's nothing
bigger seven versus
three I think we upset them this year oh
I think we
upset this is the
Year this is the
Year this is the Year this is the year I
need to see it chop Robinson Adisa
Isaac I need to see it y'all gota hunt
y'all gota go get after him kayin King
it's time you want to get paid hey they
got one of them ones over there across
the off they got got a couple of them
hey day day I need to see it it's time
this the Year y'all know who I got we
are y'all know who I got we
are uh the I'm ready I want to see how
our defense controls Ohio State that's
gonna be the biggest thing in this game
I think Drew has been amazing this year
he's been putting up places he's been
taking the right throws and everything
like that but it's going to come down
how many stops we get and can we create
turnovers if we can create
turnovers and we can dominate the line
of scrimmage we can win this game we can
win this game we're gonna give us a chot
to beat Michigan and get a chot and not
only the Big 10 Championship but we're
gonna get a shot at the National
Championship in the final four but this
is the first one we gotta we gotta
control the first game and it's this one
this one right here y'all know who I got
let's Okay chat let's see who you got
who do you have Penn State or Ohio
State I mean Michigan are we for real I
mean Michigan is a great team that's
that I think Michigan is better than
Ohio State but if we don't beat Ohio
State it's gonna set us back from
beating Michigan we got to get to Ohio
State first we gotta focus on Ohio State
but Michigan is the real deal without a
doubt I I've seen Michigan um it's like
they're playing a man amongst boys I
mean the hard ball turned out way around
from where they used to be um man and
they look special but we got to beat we
got to beat Ohio State this week have to
I already talked to Coach Franklin um
we're very excited but chat I want to
hear questions from y'all uh ask me
anything um I want to hear
feedback
uh yeah I did hear the commentators
talking trash uh right before I got the
sack and I just feel like they obviously
don't be watching the same game that I
have I mean I felt like I was dominant I
was getting pretty much close every year
um but it is what it is I'm just glad I
got him and I was able to to go like
this just go like this uh what do I
think about Julio Jones join the Eagles
I don't think too much uh julo Jones
obviously a great player future Hall of
Famer player um but they're so loaded
already it's like where do where do you
put him who do you start him over is he
a rotational guy um because ajel Brown's
been amazing this year Devonte Smith
amazing this year um do you just make
him your number three um because it's
been low questionable right there uh
Julio if you have Julio Jones as a
number three receiver you're in the
right place I mean that's I mean that's
amazing uh especially the talent he is
and who he is I mean that's that's
amazing uh flag football is coming to
the Olympics in 2028 who should be on
the US team I'm going on the US team I'm
going to go win an Olympic gold medal
because I can't do it in track and I
can't do anything else but I know I can
play some flag football I think I might
be playing offense for the guys so uh
I'll be joining the team I heard Tyreek
say he joining so me and Tyreek is going
to started off and it's just gonna be
just like that we gonna start it off I
all our guys should be in that team we
need Justin Jefferson out there we need
Jamar Chas CD lamb we should have we
should run through everybody just like
we do in wrestling and everything else
we should run through everything um and
and it's just point blank period uh
Maris Bell should get his F from last
night's performance um you're talking
about a guy that we signed at udfa um
he's came in and been nothing but work
he started off at safety transition to a
linebacker and I think that's what's
special about uh Dan Quinn he's not
afraid to test his players limits uh you
know he transitioned linebacker about
two three week at the beginning of the
year and he did nothing but get better
get better wait for his turn and he took
advantage of his opportunity yesterday
could be more proud of that guy he's
going to continue to get better and he's
gonna continue to put sides on and be a
great player for us and potentially be a
great a top linebacker in this league if
he keeps doing
that you said Sofi is a top three
Stadium what are your other two my other
two stadiums are Minnesota Stadium um
and obviously AT&T uh I think those is
some amazing stadiums um I've been in a
lot of other great stadiums but you know
I think it's always electric when we're
in those uh three stadiums I mean I mean
it's just always amazing like it's crazy
um y said Stefon Diggs is number two
this year 100% um I'm not taking away
anything from Stefon Diggs he You could
argue any one of them five um especially
with you know Jets being out you can
throw Stefon Diggs in there but you know
just off the history of it these guys
just been so efficient in this league
and dominating League since they came in
so it's just hard to uh take him away
you know and you know Stefon Dig's my
dog and you know he's a top 10 top five
however you want to argue receiver for
sure um but those those just my my top
five right now and that's just me you
know um you can argue every way you want
to argue it uh who do I have winning the
AFC East man I that's tough uh I'm not
sure right now because it's so
competitive it's so it's so competitive
especially because how do the Bills the
bills has been playing when Josh Allen
is on he's on like and especially how
they won to uh it's going to come down
to the wire it's something I'm might
have to give you that answer sometime
later on probably after Thanksgiving
break uh heading into December football
where really starting to break down I'm
gonna give you that answer um I'm
watching your podcast during class with
your jersey on just know I appreciate
you uh I always support the love I
always show back love to the people who
support me the most um that's always a
mad mad love uh because I wouldn't be
here without the people that believe in
me so just keep keep believing uh stay
true and I appreciate you a lot uh we're
on a by week what does a typical by week
mean for me um we usually come in like
today we lift uh we'll run we watch film
break down of the game and then you know
the rest of the week we get to chill
I'll be chilling in Dallas I'm gonna go
see the Rangers tomorrow so Texas stand
up we got to keep this train going we're
gonna go see the Rangers tomorrow super
excited about that uh and Thursday you
know I'm GNA fly back home uh to go see
my back in Harrisburg so it's always
good to see the fam and uh you know just
get get away from everything you know
just just come home and just be at peace
get away from football and just get
around the people that love you the most
and that that's always important uh stay
neutral and staying you know grounded as
much as you can you know because family
without family we're nothing uh they're
part of you know that's part of your why
you know besides God so I appreciate
everybody for tuning in for the edge
this week it's gonna keep getting more
intense more energy more class and a lot
of things you're going to see out there
in these other places and social media
stay off social media we don't
appreciate these social media bullies
anyway we gonna keep it TR right here on
the edge with your boy Michael Parsons I
appreciate it y'all hey keep believing
Cowboy Nation hey we gonna enjoy this by
we we gonna see y'all next week AT&T
Stadium we got tough one we got Stafford
Cooper cup and Nico that's going to come
here and ran on our parade but uh it's
going to come down to business it's
going to be super exciting great match
up we'll get into that next week can't
wait to see y'all hey love y'all Cowboy
Nation how about them
[Music]
Cowboys